I'm glozell and I'm from Orlando Florida
O'Town this is so sub that only Florida
people will know you're going to feel
the heat hit you right on the face it's
like the universe is going they say we
don't have seasons we have season we
have hot
we have extra hot we have super hot and
we have crispy okay now Florida state
bird it's a mosquito it will go right
through up and bite on islands growing
up it was nothing to me to see a
alligator on the side of the road just
minding his own business you know I'm
saying just like back in time the spirit
in because they haven't really involved
it just like a long green thumb thing if
you're from Florida you're part of one
or two teams the right one and the wrong
one go Gators University of Florida go
Gators Chomp Chomp in that other one it
is acceptable only in Florida to wear
flip-flops and when I say everywhere I
mean everywhere you can wear them to
weddings you can wear them to funerals
you can wear to graduations I don't
understand it's not like people polish
them to make them dress the upper people
come to visit guess where they want to
go anybody have again there's the world
okay when you from Orlando like I am I'm
going to Disney World at least seven
hundred and forty two thousand pounds
they don't realize it cause like a house
image to go out there and see that rest
everybody comes to Florida for spring
break which means what
say kitties and girls gone wild okay so
your parents will get upset with you but
everybody's got to do it Hey with the
Christmas thing going on most people
think you have like a pine tree or
something like that we will put some
Christmas lights on a palm tree in a
minute name nothing but a thing for us
looks normal to me
Florida we have great music great food
we might have a few killers here and
there but it's a great time I have to
talk about Florida but you can haha
over and out
Oh